[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un jour particulier à
star fratellam à 300 km au sud du Caire
Yasser va enfin être raccordé au réseau
d'eau potable paysan et père de 5
enfants il dit adieu au risque quotidien
lié à une ou un salut pour
elle vient de sous la terre ce sont des
eaux souterraines elle est insalubre
elle n'est pas saine il y a du sable et
les mauvaises pour les enfants et les
gens jusque là il y a certes consommées
de l'eau non traitée puisée grâce à
cette pompe illégale l'UNICEF le fond
des Nations unies pour l'enfance lui a
fait un prêt de 130 dollars qui devra
rembourser en deux ans désormais il va
pouvoir voir de l'eau saine en toute
légalité
mais je n'ai pas les moyens de payer
même 4000 livres je suis un homme pauvre
les eaux du Nil symbole de prospérité en
Égypte depuis l'Antiquité sont désormais
devenus insuffisantes pour subvenir aux
besoins d'une population en constante
augmentation d'autant que l'Éthiopie a
construit le gigantesque barrage de la
Renaissance en amont lui permettant de
réguler le débit du fleuve depuis cette
année
98% des 109 millions d'habitants du pays
en sont directement dépendants à 500 km
plus au nord se trouve les terres
fertiles du delta véritable grenier à
blé de l’égypte ici on utilise l'eau des
affluents du Nil depuis toujours pour
irriguer les champs
alors vous voyez l'eau elle vient d'ici
elle part par là
[Musique]
Mohamed El Saïd cultive du riz et doit
noyer ses terres alors que l'agriculture
représente 80% de la consommation d'eau
potable en Egypte le gouvernement a
imposé un contrôle plus strict de
l'utilisation des ressources
nous avons trois ou quatre jours d’eau
et deux ou trois jours secs
entièrement inondé
un peu d'eau pour ceux qui veulent en
ajouter un peu l'eau est quand même
disponible il n'y a pas de problème
ce système de rotation de convient pas à
tout le monde plus au nord dans des
terres moins riches la famille de soprix
cultive le jute depuis dégénérations
très consommateur en eau lui aussi mais
il doit passer après les autres
aussi tout le monde veut régler
nous essayons de travailler les uns
après les autres
et parfois la priorité est donnée au riz
qui est une culture prioritaire pour
l'État
prioritaires mais les rendements ne sont
pas les mêmes
[Musique]
alors le riz passe avant
depuis plus de 10 ans avec la hausse du
niveau de la Méditerranée la
stalinisation des grades des terres de
soprix ils se sont découragés
je suis né ici mais il n'y a plus rien
où vais-je aller
je vais devoir tout quitter et partir
c'est fini je vais devoir tenter ma
chance ailleurs
pour aider les paysans le gouvernement
égyptien a investi massivement avec
l'aide de fonds internationaux dans le
traitement de l'eau la centrale de
gabalafar et la plus grande du genre en
Afrique et au Moyen-Orient
chaque jour elle prête les eaux usées de
12 millions d'habitants plus de la
moitié de la population du Caire
nous utilisons cette eau pour les
travaux agricoles
au lieu d'utiliser une grande quantité
d'eau potable nous fournissons au
paysans de l'autre côté
là nous produisons 2,5 millions de
mètres cubes par jour et on espère
arriver en 2027 à 3,5 millions
dans un pays où les inégalités sociales
sont croissantes les stations balnéaires
privées destinées au classes moyennes
supérieur se multiplient le long de la
Méditerranée toute la côte à l'ouest
d'Alexandrie a été bétonné mais le Nil
n'arrive pas jusqu'ici
alors il faut puiser dans des nappes
phréatiques ou s'infiltre l'eau de mer
cette entrepreneur a installé une
vingtaine de petites unités de
désalinisation dans ces villages
vacances le long de la côte celles-ci
alimentent 700 foyers en eau potable
c'est très pratique parce que c'est une
usine intégrée dans un conteneur que
vous pouvez déplacer
vous avez juste à le connecter et vous
avez votre eau
dans ce cas nous ferons des puits et les
puits sont adaptés mais seulement à
cette échelle on ne peut pas s'assurer
que ça résout les problèmes mais c'est
une partie de la solution alors que le
pays voit ses ressources s'épuiser
l'Égypte va devoir relever le défi de sa
gestion de l'eau d'autant que sa
population pourrait atteindre 160
millions d'habitants en 2050